flu virus hitting nationwide causes more
deaths in hospital hospitalization and a
higher number of cases the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention reports
the flu is now widespread in 46 states
that's nearly four times as many as
compared with the same time last year 21
year old Kyler Bachmann died last week
just days after coming down with the flu
the physical fitness enthusiast
reportedly did not have a flu shot dr.
Tara Narula is here with why this season
is so dangerous
Kara good morning good morning Jon flu
seasons are notoriously difficult to
predict and this one got off to an
earlier start than usual at the center
of the threat is a more aggressive
strain of the virus making the disease
even harder to control one in roughly
10,000 children under the age of 4 have
been hospitalized with the flu this
season eight month old Kingston Smith is
one of them with his mother sharika
right by his bedside about four days ago
he started breathing hard vomiting
having fever so I drove here to the
hospital and you know say yes we need to
keep him the diagnosis can get gravely
serious of the more than a hundred
people who have died from the flu so far
this season 13 are children dr. Claire
bikini is an infectious disease
specialist at Texas Children's Hospital
unfortunately it can cause a lot of
complications children can get severely
sick actually need to be in the ICU
making the problem worse this season is
the type of flu that's spreading h3n2
this strain tends to hit younger and
older people harder than others this is
a bad bug dr. daniel Jernigan is the
director of the influenza division at
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention in years where there is H 3 &
2 we do see that there are more deaths
why is there so much activity in the
past few weeks well it's hard to say but
it's possible that a lot of folks got
together during the winter holidays and
so with all those folks getting together
they're able to transmit flu and then
take it and send it on to other folks
and so there's been a lot of that a lot
of cold air a lot of cold this season
and so because of those things we can
see a lot of influenza that gets
transmitted
flu vaccines have been less effective in
fighting h3n2 than other influenza flu
viruses making this particular strain
more difficult to contain it is still
too soon to say just how bad this flu
season will be but the CDC believes it
could reach near epidemic levels and you
can still get a flu shot
you can and you should Thank You Tara